it's Disney Plus time do you want coke
Oh Mickey uh-oh get out of there
[Laughter]
Disney's been my favorite since I'm a
child and I'm still a child at heart I'm
48 years old all right it will work
Premium fur when the app wasn't working
my wife started having a panic attack
and she fell on the kitchen floor and
she started turning kind of like a
purple color because she couldn't
breathe but I liked it because it
reminded me of Ursula we're never gonna
let our childhood ads right flounder we
asked our local pizzeria if they could
make the pizzas in the shape of Mickey
Mouse ears you know but a day they now
they'll they'll call the police if they
see our number on the caller ID
everybody's mad about politics I'm
voting for Mickey
that's who I'm voting for I'm voting for
Mickey I told my wife that I'm excited
to have children but she'll probably
have to do it with another man's semen
because the one time I came at her and I
said I'm not doing that again
so I'm really excited to show another
man's children Disney World